[Applaudissements]
ma mère l'emmène chez le dermato c'est
une vraie ce taux réellement mal chez le
dermato et le dermato me regarde et
c'est la première phrase il dit écoutez
je vous promets que vous n'aurez plus de
boutons à partir de maintenant je dis
mais comment au point d'être sûr il dit
maya plus de place à 9 heures
[Applaudissements]
c'était si tu te rends compte ce qui
s'est passé à l'esc est dynamique savez
des articles et là a dit vous avez
couché ddd et des [ __ ] hockey fait
d'entre eux via le player mais bon sur
l'oeil accès aux prix amanekh qui est le
danser avec deux girafes et de diable
capucines dans l'émission tout à l'heure
a reconnu mais qu'elle avait vécu une
très belle histoire de trois à quatre
mois
ah ah avec quelle musique l adhésion
elle est tellement très belle très belle
histoire d'amour oui beaucoup de
sentiments et puis malheureusement il a
il a appris les bacs et vers d'autres
aventures
voilà je trouve ça plutôt bien expliqué
wes a fauché une autre version
[Rires]
mais ce qui est très mignon c'est qu'un
jour dans la loge du magal est venu me
voir elle m'a dit voilà c'est fini et
tout mais franchement il me manque et je
regrette mon histoire avec ce qu'elle
m'avait dit je trouve ça mignon on ne
regrette plus est très amoureux elle est
ok vous en êtes où moi je sais avec gâte
à côté ils sont énervés vanilla
oui on a dit
oui c'est ça